donald trump franchi un nouveau cap dans
son bras de fer avec la chine cette fois
ci le locataire de la maison blanche je
remets tout simplement en cause le
statut spécial qui lie les états unis à
hong kong
il menace de supprimer les privilèges
commerciaux de l'ancienne colonie
britannique
une annonce qui vient compléter une
série de mesures de rétorsion contre
pékin en réponse d'après le président
américain à la décision de la chine
d'imposer une nouvelle loi sécuritaire à
hong kong donald trump qui annonce
également des sanctions contre les
officiels chinois et hong kong est qu'il
accuse d'avoir directement ou
indirectement contribué à réduire
l'autonomie de hong kong
c'est une tragédie pour le peuple de
hong kong pour le peuple de la chine et
pour le monde entier
dans la foulée donald trump annonce la
fin de la participation américaine à l'
oms l'organisation mondiale de la santé
la raison invoquée l'organisation serait
trop indulgente avec la chine dans la
gestion de la crise du coronavirus nous
avons détaillé les réformes que l' oms
devait engager directement avec la chine
mais l'organisation a refusé à cause de
ce refus d'engager des réformes
nous nous retirons immédiatement de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
allons nous tourner vers d'autres
organisations publiques dans le monde
qui méritent notre aide
[Musique]
avec le retrait américain l'organisation
risque de perdre entre 15 et 20% de son
budget cette décision peut flatter une
base électorale
opposé à l'impôt et au multilatéralisme
mais elle pourrait se révéler contre
productive sur le plan de la sécurité
sanitaire mondiale et enfin dernière
annonçait la mise en place de
restrictions d'entrée sur le territoire
américain pour les étudiants et les
chercheurs chinois pendant des années la
chine s'est livré à des activités
d'espionnage illicites pour voler nos
secrets aujourd'hui je vais prendre des
mesures
protéger nos universités les plus
importantes et suspendre l'entrée de
certains ressortissants chinois que nous
avons identifié comme un risque
potentiel de sécurité la concomitance
des attaques tous azimuts contre la
chine
avec le calendrier électoral américain
n'a pas échappé à l'opposition démocrate
le président veut détourner l'attention
accordée à ces manquements vers la chine
donc il fait ce qu'il faut pour de
mauvaises raisons alors que les
élections présidentielles américaines
approchent à grands pas le président
sortant est actuellement très fragilisé
il doit affronter non seulement les
critiques sur sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire
une crise économique sans précédent mais
aussi des tensions raciales ramener ces
derniers jours dans tout le pays